NARRATOR: 30 years
ago, we discovered
man-made chemicals had punched
a hole in the ozone layer.
Is that hole here to stay,
waiting around to kill us?
Today, we're trying
hard to find out.
Morgan Sandercock is about to
test an experimental plane,
perfect for sampling ozone.
MAN: (ON RADIO) Copy that.
So I felt pressure rising.
MORGAN SANDERCOCK:
(VOICEOVER) We think we
can go as high as 90,000 feet.
MAN: (ON RADIO) Jim,
you ready to go?
JIM PAYNE: (ON
RADIO) We're ready.
MORGAN SANDERCOCK: (VOICEOVER)
That's the big boy territory.
That's where things can go
wrong very, very quickly.
If we lose cabin
pressure, then, the pilots
could very easily pass out.
And we don't have any automatic
systems to recover from that.
WOMAN: (ON RADIO)
Getting ready to roll.
NARRATOR: Now, a glider might
sound like a dangerous choice
so high up.
But gliders don't have
engines, which means they can't
pollute the team's samples.
MAN: (ON RADIO) Confirm
[inaudible] off.
WOMAN: (ON RADIO)
[inaudible] is off.
Wing wheel is off.
MAN: (ON RADIO) Been
running at 11:32.
MAN: (ON RADIO) 11:32.
Written down in GPS 5.
MAN: (ON RADIO) Airborne.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: The Perlan
glider uses air
rising over the Southern Andes
to reach extraordinary heights.
MAN: (ON RADIO)
Airspeed, 70 knots.
Looking beautiful.
MAN: (ON RADIO) Yeah?
MAN: (ON RADIO) Really high.
MAN: (ON RADIO) Traffic.
MAN: (ON RADIO) Yeah.
NARRATOR: 52,000 feet up makes
this the highest glider flight
ever.
But you've got to get this
high to get a great picture
of the ozone layer.
The good news is that
thanks to a global ban
on ozone-harming
chemicals, it looks
like the hole is healing up.
Our shield is regenerating.